and how many of you have brands or focus
on your own personal brand I mean yeah I
don't feel like we really have that
choice I mean there is such a you know
sense of needing to stand out otherwise
you know as you were saying everything
can eventually be replaced or a lot
amended and especially if you're in any
sort of entertainment you have to have a
yes because nobody's doing it for you I
think it creates a bit of tension with
professionalism like we were talking
about absolutely kind of have to stand
that in person and it looks like on line
to where I differ in a big way I'm and
maybe it's the industry that I'm in but
I like to put minimal information online
I like to be more professional and and
build my brand in person I think that's
also like almost like a new form of a
resume because you almost like oh what
do you do well here's my website I write
and so in order to get people to read my
words I use social media like I have
2,500 something you know Facebook
friends I don't talk to 2,500 people but
and I've wanted to cleanse my facebook
you know friends list about 1200 or
something which but my friend but my
friends will be like I need people to
read